it is 2017 and it is time for the first
hatred mail really hatred males cuz we
have two for you today of the year I'll
remind you what hatred mail is it's like
a mandatory transvaginal ultrasound for
your mind Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right
with the vacation last week a lot of
tweets coming in people saying I'm
having hatred mail withdrawal so we are
doubling up this week let's get to the
first of two hatred mail starting off
2017 very very strongly David Pakman go
away
you're just another snot-nosed
millennial punk who needs to dry up and
blow away like a dried up leaf Joo
Pakman Trump one [ __ ] and your
boyfriend Louis left you David Pakman is
the scam artist
another Pakman lie homosexuals will lie
about everything we're building up a
profile of the most common things uh
that that exist in hatred mail one of
them and you probably you'd only if you
were watching did you see this your why
oh you apostrophe re almost without fail
is written as why oh you are and that
happened in this age email that's like I
would say if we had a list and we check
a box off every time we see some of
these things the your your thing is very
very common and of course some criticism
based on the incorrect assessment of me
is a quote homosexual or sometimes other
words are used those are two of the top
trends in hatred mail you're also called
millennial and it correct me if I'm
wrong but I don't think you you're a
part of them are well I am I am okay I
live in Gen X I believe no Thank You Pat
I appreciate Pat who is six months old
when the show started commenting on on
my age uh no I believe that it goes back
to isn't it 1980 Rachel the first year
that the Millennial
Millennials started in 1980 it is so you
just make the cutoff at by met by almost
five years yet I should add yes thank
you to both of you uh okay yeah so now
that we've established that part that
part was accurate we can all say I think
the hatred mail was was completely
accurate about me being a
niall let's now go to hatred mail number
2 of the day trump has already created
85,000 to 90,000 jobbies he has not even
took office the stock market is at the
best it of has been in over 15 years
only an idiot would not want Trump as
president Pakman is a dishonest
homosexual right is just as bad as CNN
this Pakman [ __ ] fake news once again
of course the critique that my perceived
sexual orientation is part of the
problem with this program the thing I
don't get is if the stock the stock
market is at record highs the hay tree
recognizes that if that's true how is
that any way justifying Donald Trump's
presidency it's under President Obama
that we've seen the stock market more
than double I don't get it and this is
also fake news somehow - oh yeah well
that's the new thing and you have you
seen this trend racial of when if you
don't like any if you don't like someone
they're a [ __ ] okay that's one you think
if you don't like what a news station is
saying it's just fake news that's now
the trend among the kids these days yeah
it's kind of the ultimate insult that if
they're putting it on the person behind
the news yeah yeah that it's a bi by
association that's about as low as it
goes remember hatred mail can become
something positive if you use the coupon
code hatred for tea a david pakman.com
slash membership you will get a major
major discount it's a way to shake your
fist at those damn hey tree 'it's